>> Laura: FOX NEWS CONFIRMS
THAT FBI OFFICIAL ANDREW
McCABE ASKED DOJ OFFICIALS
TODAY NOT TO FIRE HIM BEFORE
HIS RETIREMENT TAKES EFFECT
ON SUNDAY.
PINK SLIP COULD COST HIM HIS
PENSION BENEFITS.
McCABE OVERSAW THE FBI
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY'S
EMAIL SCANDAL BUT THE FORMER
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANNOUNCED
HIS RESIGNATION IN JANUARY
TO AVOID A LIKELY DEMOTION.
THE FBI REPORTEDLY
RECOMMENDED FIRING McCABE
AFTER WORD LEAKED THAT THE
DOJ'S INSPECTOR GENERAL
CONCLUDED THAT McCABE
MISLEAD INVESTIGATORS.
TO DISCUSS THIS AND OTHER
DEVELOPMENTS WITH FORMER FBI
SPOKESPERSON JOHN AN REALLY
AND WISENBURG DEPUTY
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL UNDER
KEN STARR.
LET ME START WITH YOU ON
THIS.
McCABE HAS ALL THIS JUNK
IN HIS PAST.
HIS WIFE, YOU KNOW, GETTING
HELP FROM HILLARY'S FRIEND.
AND NOT REVEALING IT, OF
COURSE.
AND THEN, OF COURSE,
EVERYBODY IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE WAY HE HANDLED THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
AND NOW HE IS SET TO RETIRE
ON SUNDAY.
IS IT A LITTLE LATE TO BE
TALKING ABOUT FIRING HIM?
I MEAN, IF THEY WERE GOING
TO FIRE HIM.
WHY WAIT UNTIL LIKE THURSDAY
OR FRIDAY RIGHT BEFORE HE
RETIRES?
THAT JUST SEEMS BIZARRE TO
ME.
>> IT'S BIZARRE AND IT'S A
LITTLE UNSETTLING AND EVEN A
LOT OF MY FRIENDS WHO ARE IN
THE BUREAU AND FORMER BUREAU
ARE A LITTLE UPSET WITH THE
TIMING OF IT.
TO COME IN TWO OR THREE DAYS
FOR THE HEAD OF OPR WITHIN
THE BUREAU TO COME IN TWO OR
THREE DAYS BEFORE HIS
RETIREMENT AND PUT A.G.
SESSIONS IN THAT SITUATION
IS A LITTLE BIT WEIRD.
AND YOU KNOW, LAURA, I AM NO
FAN OF HOW McCABE HAS
HANDLED THESE THINGS.
KEEP IN MIND, THAT THE ONLY
WAY AN FBI AGENT IS GOING TO
REALLY LOSE HIS PENSION IS
NOT THROUGH GENERAL
MISCONDUCT.
IT IS THROUGH BASICALLY NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH, BEING
DISHONEST.
THAT'S WHAT THE SUPPOSED
ALLEGATION IS AND, OF
COURSE, WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
OIG REPORT.
WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE WHAT
IT IS.
THERE IS JUST SOMETHING A
LITTLE BIT TROUBLING ABOUT
THE TIMING AND THE PERSON
WHO HEADS UP OPR WITHIN THE
FBI IS NOT.
>> Laura: OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
>> RIGHT.
A LOT OF HER RULINGS HAVE
BEEN YEAR TURNED, YOU KNOW,
UP HE HAD TEXAS LEVEL.
IN FACT, THE PEOPLE THAT SHE
HAS DISCIPLINED WHO THEN
COME BACK ARE KNOWN AS
BOOMERANGS IN THE BUREAU
BECAUSE A LOT OF HER RULINGS
ARE OVERTURNED.
>> Laura: IT IS, AGAIN,
ESTABLISHED, IS IT NOT,
JOHN, THAT WE HAD A
SITUATION WHERE McCABE DID
NOT REVEAL THE EXTENT OF THE
HELP HIS WIFE RECEIVED FROM
A VERY CLOSE FRIEND OF
HILLARY CLINTON WHEN ANDREW
McCABE WAS LEADING THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAIL SERVER.
OF COURSE, TERRY MCAULIFF
CONNECTED GIVEN SEVERAL
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
HIS WIFE'S FAILED BID TO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE.
>> THAT'S ALL TRUE.
AND ALL DUE RESPECT TO SOL.
I'M GOING TO DISAGREE.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS IF
THEY DID SOMETHING AFTER HE
RETIRES, THERE IS NO
REPERCUSSIONS.
YOUR PENSION IS NOT A
GUARANTEED GIFT.
WHEN YOU ARE AN FBI AGENT,
IT'S ABOUT LIVING UP TO THE
PROTOCOLS AND POLICIES,
HONESTY AND INTEGRITY.
WOULD YOU RATHER THAT HE BE
ALLOWED TO RETIRE EVEN
THOUGH SOMETHING MAY HAVE
BEEN DONE WRONG AND IT WAS
DETERMINED BY OPR YET, HE
CAN BENEFIT.
AGENTS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR BEHAVIORS.
AND I THINK THIS SPEAKS TO
MANY THINGS THAT HAPPENED
WHEN MR. McCABE WAS
WORKING FOR DIRECTOR COMEY.
>> Laura: SARAH HUCKABEE
TODAY ON THE VIEW SAID THIS
IS FOR JEFF SESSIONS TO
DECIDE BUT IT WAS AT A
BRIEFING.
SHE REITERATED HE WAS A BAD
ACTOR IN THEIR VIEW.
SO KIND OF GAVE THE DRIVE BY
BUT IS HE A BAD ACTOR BUT
THIS IS UP TO JEFF SESSIONS.
THIS IS WHAT THAT WE NOUNED
LEGAL SCHOLAR SONNY SAID ON
THE VIEW.
WATCH.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THIS WAR ON
OUR INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
OR THIS WAR ON THE FBI.
I MEAN, THIS MAN IS A CAREER
AGENT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DID OR
DID NOT DO, BUT I AM
TROUBLED WITH THIS CONSTANT
ATTACK ON OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
>> YEAH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> BECAUSE THAT IS THE STUFF
THAT DICTATORS ARE MADE OF.
>> Laura: THE STUFF THAT
DICTATORS ARE MADE OF
BECAUSE THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY NEVER GETS
ANYTHING WRONG, SOL, THEY
NEVER MAKE A MISTAKE AND
NEVER GET ANYTHING WRONG.
OKAY, 9/11.
HELLO.
>> IT'S A RIDICULOUS
COMMENT.
BUT, AGAIN, KEEP IN MIND,
AGENTS, SUPERVISORS, WHOEVER
THEY ARE WITHIN THE BUREAU,
PENSION, WHICH IS THE
PROBABLY THE BEST PENSION IN
THE WHOLE U.S. GOVERNMENT
FOR THIS DISHONESTY.
THAT KIND OF DISHONORABLE
CONDUCT.
HE WOULD NEVER LOSE HIS
PENSION.
EVEN IF HE REALLY WAS A BAD
ACTOR IN THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, SO, IF WE
JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN
THE REPORT.
SO, IF IT'S INCREDIBLY
DETAILED AND INCREDIBLY
DAMNING AND SESSIONS HAS A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT AND
MAKE THAT DECISION IN TWO OR
THREE DAYS.
THAT'S ONE THING.
BUT THAT'S A VERY BIG DEAL
TO COME IN AND PRESENT THIS
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH
ONLY TWO OR THREE DAYS FOR
HIM TO LOOK AT IT.
AND, AGAIN, I THINK OF THIS
PARTICULAR PERSON, THE HEAD
OF OPR.
SHE DIDN'T DO THE
INVESTIGATION.
SHE JUST TOOK THE OIG'S
REPORT.
SO I'M TROUBLED BY THE
TIMING.
IT THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT.
>> Laura: SESSIONS MAY HAVE
SEEN -- GOTTEN A SNEAK
PREVIEW, RIGHT, JOHN, OF
WHAT'S IN THAT IG REPORT.
HE ALREADY KNOWS BASICALLY
WHAT'S IN IT.
SO IF IT COMES OUT AS REALLY
BAD ON McCABE, I HAVE A
PENSION, GREAT.
THAT ALSO LOOKS ODD.
>> IT DOES.
THE REALITY IS IN THE FBI
THERE IS MANY THINGS THAT
CAN BE FORGIVEN, YET
PUNISHED, BUT LACK OF
CANDOR, NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH IS UNFOREGIIVEL.
AGENTS AND SUPPORT EMPLOYEES
WILL BE TERMINATED FOR THAT
TYPE OF THING TO HAPPEN AND
THERE ARE NO EXCEPTIONS.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
MESSAGE WHEN THERE HAS BEEN
LEADERSHIP PROBLEMS AT TIMES
IN THE FBI THAT NO ONE CAN
ESCAPE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE JOB.
>> Laura: INVESTIGATIONS
LOOK LIKE THEY ARE AT THEIR
VERY CORE POLITICIZED, TALK
ABOUT UNDERMINING THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE FBI AND
INTEL COMMUNITY.
CALL THEM BALLS AND STRIKES
WITHOUT CONCERN FOR
POLITICS.
AND THAT'S MY CONCERN FROM
THE BEGINNING.
>> LAURA?
>> Laura: YEAH, REALLY
QUICK.
>> DON'T FORGET, THAT IF HE
REALLY MISLEAD A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION, THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL.
>> Laura: CRIME.
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTET
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEA
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEL
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEF
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTER
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEC
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEI
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEA
>> POO FENNEL TORE CRIMINALPOTEL